en johannesburgo en junio la temperatura
mínima diaria usualmente es alrededor de
3 grados celsius y la temperatura máxima
diaria alrededor de 18 grados celsius la
temperatura se ubica justo a la mitad
entre la máxima diaria y la mínima
diaria tanto a las 10 am como a las 10
pm y la temperatura máxima es por la
tarde encuentra una función
trigonométricas que modele la
temperatura t mayúscula en johannesburgo
t minúscula horas después de medianoche
para empezar intentemos graficar la
función
este va a ser nuestro eje de temperatura
este es el eje de temperatura en grados
celsius de hecho vamos a construir dos
gráficas y este el eje horizontal este
eje horizontal va a ser el eje del
tiempo t en horas ahora veamos el rango
de la temperatura la temperatura
presenta un mínimo de tres grados
celsius y tiene un máximo de 18 grados
celsius entonces aquí tenemos 18
mientras que esta de acá es 3 y el punto
medio el cual se alcanza a las 10 am y
10 pm sería 18 + 3 21 entre 2 10.5
grados este punto determina la línea
media entonces aquí en 10.5 tenemos la
línea media que es la línea alrededor de
la cual va oscilar nuestra función
trigonométricas este es entonces la
línea media mientras que el valor máximo
es d
18 grados celsius y el valor mínimo es
de 3 grados celsius de tal manera que la
temperatura diaria va a estar oscilando
alrededor de la línea media alcanzando
el valor mínimo y máximo a lo largo del
día ahora para simplificar las cosas y
dado que la temperatura es 10.5 a las 10
am y 10 pm para simplificar no voy a
encontrar por el momento la función que
nos están pidiendo en términos de t
horas después de medianoche en su lugar
voy a construir una función que voy a
llamar
efe dt que va a proporcionar la
temperatura temperatura en johannesburgo
no voy a poner esto suponemos que todo
es en johannesburgo así es que vamos a
ponerlo directamente la temperatura t
horas después de las 10 am y la razón
por la cual estoy eligiendo 10 a m es
que esa hora la temperatura está en el
punto medio
así es que temperatura t horas después
10 am y vemos que f cuando te vale 0 son
las 10 am y la temperatura se ubica nos
lo dicen
entre la temperatura mínima y la máxima
ahora cuál es el periodo de esta función
trigonométricas bien después de 24 horas
volverán a ser las 10 am así es que
nuestro periodo va a ser 24 horas aquí
tendríamos la mitad que son 12 horas y
qué pasa después de 12 horas después de
12 horas son las 10 pm y la temperatura
vuelve a ser 10.5 grados celsius y
después de 24 horas decíamos otra vez
las 10 am y la temperatura vuelve a ser
10.5 grados celsius
así es que esos son puntos de ft ahora
pensemos qué pasa al avanzar el día
después de las 10 am a partir de las 10
am nos están diciendo que las
temperaturas más altas son por la tarde
y la tarde son estas horas que se ubican
aquí así es que aquí debe subir la
temperatura y el punto más alto se debe
de alcanzar a la mitad entre estos dos
es decir a las seis horas después de las
10 a las 4 pm así es que este va a ser
el máximo déjame graficar la curva
vamos a graficar la curva sinusoidal ahí
la tenemos ya estamos a las 10pm y ahora
el mínimo se va a ubicar seis horas
después de las 10 pm cuando son las 4 am
18 horas después de las 10 am hay
ubicaríamos más o menos la temperatura
mínima vamos a completar esta curva
sinusoidal y ahí tenemos la función
efe dt ahora antes de obtener la función
tdt cual sería una expresión y aquí la
curva seguiría hacia adelante y aquí
hacia atrás antes de 10m y así
continuarían todos los días pero
entonces cuál sería una expresión para
ésta
efe dt te invito a que le pongas pausa
el vídeo e intentes encontrar la función
por tu cuenta bien lo primero que
tendríamos que considerar es una función
seno o es una función coseno se puede
modelar con cualquiera de los dos pero
hay que elegir la que sea más fácil así
es que aquí vamos a considerar cuál de
estas dos funciones se encuentra en la
línea media cuando te igual a cero bien
el seno de cero
0 y si no fuera por la traslación esta
función cruzaría el eje de la línea
media en 0 0 0 es cero empieza a crecer
para luego decrecer y así seguir
oscilando así es que parece ser que la
función se no es un buen candidato para
el modelo de nueva cuenta también podría
hacerse con función coseno pero se no
nos facilita las cosas
veamos ahora cuál es la amplitud cuál es
la máxima variación que hay con respecto
a la línea media aquí tenemos 7.5 por
arriba de la línea media mientras que
aquí tenemos 7.5 por abajo de la línea
media si es que la amplitud es 7.5
déjame ponerlo con otro color para que
veamos de dónde salen las cosas así es
que este 7.5
éste también es 7.5 y aquí la amplitud
es 7.5 y ahora cuál es el periodo bien
como ya lo habíamos mencionado el
periodo de esta función es 24 horas lo
cual a este sentido después de 24 horas
se tiene la misma temperatura así es que
vamos a dividir
entre el periodo entre 24 224 portes y
si olvides que hay que dividir dos pies
entre el periodo 224 aquí hay que
considerar los valores de t que
cubrirían todo el periodo de la función
cuando t es igual a cero entonces este
argumento se hace cero y estamos en este
valor aquí y cuando te es igual a 24
el argumento va a ser 2 pitt así es que
habremos dado una vuelta completa al
círculo unitario considerando el
argumento de la función seno ya casi la
tenemos
si yo graficar esta función vería que
oscila alrededor del eje y entonces
necesitamos trasladarla en 10.5 unidades
hacia arriba y esto lo hacemos sumando
10.5 bien ya hemos obtenido un modelo
adecuado y esto podemos simplificarlo
aquí como pi sobre 12 en lugar de 2 pi
sobre 24 sin embargo nosotros hemos
obtenido un modelo adecuado para t horas
después de las 10 am t horas después de
las 10 am
pero el problema nos pide
que lo movemos para que horas después de
medianoche entonces cuáles tdt aquí
vamos a tener que hacer una pequeña
traslación
veamos cómo es esto escribamos entonces
tdt donde está ahora si van a ser las
horas después de medianoche la amplitud
sigue siendo la misma 7.5 esa no va a
variar 7.5 que multiplica a seno de voy
a ponerlo con el mismo color para que
podamos distinguir que cambia y que no
cambia seno de 2 piso bre 24 lo voy a
escribir como pi sobre 12 que multiplica
a t y aquí es donde voy a incluir la
traslación ya sea hacia la izquierda o
hacia la derecha no importa al final de
cuenta la función se no es una función
periódica así es que le vamos a sumar o
al restar algún término eso lo vamos a
considerar en un momento más 10.5 más
10.5 y en este punto a veces me confundo
tengo que pensarlo de distintas maneras
para ver si le estoy trasladando en la
dirección correcta
en la función que hemos desarrollado
cuando te igual a cero son las 10 am
necesitamos establecer para esta de dt
cuál es el valor de t que nos da las 10
am en esta función las 10 am veámoslo
de esta manera 10 a m son 10 horas
después de medianoche así es que te de
10 t de 10 horas después de medianoche
te de 10 am tiene que ser igual a efe de
0 que definimos como la temperatura pero
horas después de 10 a n
pongámoslo aquí abajo esta de aquí es
temperatura a las 10
a m y esta de aquí que es la temperatura
10 horas después de medianoche también
es la temperatura a las 10 am queremos
entonces que t de 10 sea igual a efe de
0 por un lado
efe de ser ocurre cuando este argumento
es igual a 0 y por otro lado queremos
que este argumento sea igual a cero
cuando t es igual a 10 y como hacemos
eso haciendo el argumento de menos 10 y
observa cuando t es igual a 10 este
término se hace 0 seno de 0 es 0
así es que sólo nos queda 10.5 y cuando
está igual a 0 lo mismo esto se hace 0 y
sólo nos queda 10.5 se cumple que te dé
10 es igual a efe de 0 y si queremos
graficar esta función aunque ya hemos
contestado a la pregunta si ponemos un
10 aquí tenemos de 10 que es igual a efe
de 0 pero vamos a graficar la función
así es que vamos a ubicarte de 10 desde
10 aquí tenemos 6 12 más o menos aquí
aquí por la mitad tendríamos el 9 y el
10 estaré aquí aproximadamente a dos
tercios
de 10 es igual a efe de 0 y básicamente
lo que estamos haciendo es trasladando
la curva hacia la derecha
así es que trasladamos todo hacia la
derecha 10 unidades y eso hace sentido
pues lo que ocurre ciertas horas después
de las 10 am va a ocurrir esas ciertas
horas más 10 después de medianoche así
es que la curva vendría más o menos por
aquí este punto también lo trasladamos
10 unidades a la derecha vendría por
aquí este valor máximo estaría a las 16
horas más o menos así tendríamos nuestra
curva también para este lado
esta sería la curva de nuestra función y
lo que hicimos fue el argumento le
restamos t menos 10 al argumento y esta
es la justificación de por qué hicimos
eso